look if you've got a screw up time you
might as well do it big enough to be
called a legend well folks I am feeling
like I need to do another why it's
awesome because there's a new season
about to start of one of my favorite
shows currently airing on TV and that is
legends of tomorrow now people have
intermittently in the comments asked me
about my thoughts on the CW DC
live-action TV shows in general and I
have mixed feelings on most of them
arrow I never watch because honestly I
had no interest in and the bits I've
seen a bit through the the crossover
events didn't make me want to watch it
more I bowed out a flash after two
seasons I got I don't know maybe a
quarter of the way through
Supergirl season 3 and I'm not loving
that where that's going right now I
might honestly skip the rest of the
third season just read the wiki and hope
that it gets good again with the fourth
I got through about the first half of
Black Lightning and then kind of just
fell off but I do intend to get back to
that one but I haven't gotten haven't
gotten there yet and you know overall
like it's fun it's fine but then there's
legends of tomorrow and I love like so
tomorrow yeah I love it so much the
funny thing is the reason that I love it
is not that dissimilar from part of the
reason that I love Gotham which is that
it is not afraid to go nuts and it knows
it's ridiculous and that is also one of
the things I love about Gotham but
whereas Gotham pairs that with a with a
sense of darkness this has a sense of
just fun to it so in explaining what I
like about legends of tomorrow I like to
single out one scene from I believe it
was the second season that
me is everything I is the the heart of
what I love about this show in a
nutshell and this is a scene where the
legends and this is a time-travel show
if you didn't already know the the
legends have gone back to Arthurian
times and you know they they're trying
to dress the part and look and you know
most of them you know done up as fair
maidens and knights in shining armour
and the one guy on the team who's a
historian he always done up like a dirty
peasant because it's like you guys look
ridiculous and you know this this is the
real world this is not some glossy shiny
thing you are all gonna stand out like a
sore thumb at which point King Arthur
and his Knights ride up looking all
shiny and pristine and going what's up
with the one dirty guy that's what this
show is it is not historically accurate
because historical accuracy isn't fun
that is the heart of this show the
choices that it makes aren't because
it's the choice that makes the most
logical sense or because it's the choice
that makes the most historical sense
when they do historically set up so it's
the choice that makes the story the most
fun that is why I love this show so
before I get too much gues gushing let
me get an acknowledgement out of the way
the first season is the weakest season
and that largely comes down to well two
things
hawkman and hawkgirl they both kind of
suck hot girl especially is a special
breed of useless like she is not a
particularly engaging character but she
is core and central to the over to the
season long arc going on with that
particular season and she she had one
job it was the epitome of you had one
job and she sucks at it so I really
don't like the Hawks at all thankfully
they're gone after the first season and
after that there really isn't a reliably
weak link there are some characters
where I like more than others but
there's no
was a drag on it once they were gotten
rid of so who is in this thing well it
depends on the season because some
characters get introduced later and some
exit at some point but some of the
characters we've got here we've got
Captain Cold
and we've got his partner heatwave now
the two of these two together are really
really great these are these are career
criminals who are basically just trying
out the hero thing cuz yeah why not
heatwave especially McCrory he loved
Mick so much he is so grouchy and so
focused on just his his own immediate
desires which is usually a beer or to
set something on fire those are the two
things that bring him pleasure more than
anything else although he ends up having
like little other things that he likes
to like one of my favorite lines from
make the there they're in their ship
their time travel ship it's called the
Waverider and it's about to get hit with
these missiles and everyone's like
they're all strapped in and bracing for
impact and everyone's going like ah and
Mick's there with a book going all of
you shut up I'm on the last page
I love make so much but snart aka
Captain Cold Leonard snart yeah did you
know that was his name he's also great
just be a pig just such biting snark
he's called snart he might as well be
called snark holy cow this guy some of
the other characters we have Ray Palmer
aka the atom being played by Brandon
Roth the one-time Superman and he's just
kind of lovable he's he's one of the
characters who's he's not my favorite
but he's he's nice and reliable and he's
sweet he's kind of the reliably upbeats
looking for the most positive outcome
kind of guy you've got Nate who's the
historian who I mentioned who has his
dumbass moments sometimes he annoys me
but the guy means
really well and now I can roll with that
you've got ooh you've got Sarah Lance
the white canary Sarah Lance eventually
kind of become this team leader and
she's awesome like she wants to try and
do things right because they're always
going to these different periods in time
and trying to fix things that are wrong
half the time it's something that they
caused the problem in the first place
and her general approach is look we're
gonna go in out minimal you know
disturbance we're gonna be real you know
clean and professional about this but
then at a certain point when things
aren't lining up she's she's gonna go ah
screw it and just break everything and
get the result that she wants to
regardless of the mess that kids left um
so I love that about her and she's also
I would say one of the better explicitly
bisexual characters currently in
mainstream media I don't know if the
actual word bisexual ever gets stated I
don't remember it being used but she is
still explicitly bisexual because she
has been shown hooking up with men and
with women and going back and forth
between the two she's an awesome Carrie
she's got great chemistry with actually
pretty much everybody in the show has
good chemistry with each other she has
great chemistry with everybody because
she again she means well she wants the
best out of this team but man is she had
it with their BS sometimes we've got rip
hunter who is you know he he's the
closest thing to a by-the-book guy but
even he's like yeah these are the rules
but we're not really gonna do that and
rip is just a fun sort of adventurous
kind of character a little bit kind of
swashbuckling edge to him so that's
always fun
you've got firestorm made up of two
halves if you if you don't know how
firestorm works firestorm is an odd
superhero who is the the combination of
a young athletic man in a much older
kind of stodgy academic and they merge
together and have fire powers and that's
that's firestorm so that's Jax and
that's professor Stein
and again terrific chemistry great
rapport great development of that
relationship as they they each come to
appreciate the other more and more as
time goes on later on we get Amaya who
has these sort of animal totem powers
and she she has that sort of sense of
wisdom to her without ever becoming you
know the the y-you know the wise sort of
connected to her ancestry cliche she
does feel still feel like you know a
real a properly developed character
that's just an element of what's going
on more recent addition is re who is
again a very nicely sarcastic character
who's just sort of looking at these
going you guys suck at this it's that's
kind of her thing there's other
characters because there's a thing
called the you know the time Bureau
which is not thrilled with the legends
that actually kind of can't stand them
there's a couple of cool characters that
we get from there that I really like
like this ensemble that's the other
thing I love about this this is an
ensemble because that was one of the
things that tended to bug me about the
other CW shows is more often than not I
found myself irritated with whoever the
lead character was that was kind of why
I bowed out from watching flash after
the second season it's not that it was
bad I just found myself more irritated
with the lead character and kind of
wanting to spend more time with all the
supporting characters there are only so
many times I could go damn it Barry and
I ended up having a similar issue with
Supergirl come season 3 but the fact
that there is not one definitive central
character of legends of tomorrow means
even if a character is annoying me next
episode is probably going to shift and
focus on somebody else unless it's the
Hawks but again they were only season 1
so I really had that ensemble nature and
that everyone gets their moment to shine
everybody gets highlighted Oh John
Constantine is now gonna be part of the
new season that's starting up yes and
Matt Ryan from the Constantine show that
was cancelled he's here he's great yeah
he was he was always a great fit for
that
part the constants in Te Constantine TV
show that God not only had a season it
was okay I feel like it was stuck in a
format that was I'm at least a decade
kind of behind the times but he was
always really good in that part and I
loved having him on board so that's
terrific
after the first season it has some
really great villains and some great
developments and like recurring
antagonist that they run into a couple
of times that are terrific the third
season the halo finale to the third
season wraps up and the wave hey defeat
what it is they're trying to defeat I
will not spoil this but oh my god it is
the kind of insanity that very few shows
could get away with but for this show it
was perfect if you've seen it hopefully
you know what I'm talking about I'm not
gonna spoil it like this one I'm really
avoiding spoilers more even more than I
usually do with why it's awesome because
like I don't know how many of my viewers
watched this of the CW shows but oh my
god this this show is so much fun and it
can still have heavier moments it can
have episodes that touch on the damage
or the histories of the or the fears of
specific characters and the things that
they've been through and it can still
hit surprisingly effective emotional
moments while also doing these insane
crazy time-traveling you know there's
Helen of Troy in the middle of you know
the Golden Age of Hollywood with Studios
warring over her like is the Mike it's
the Battle of Troy and you know it's
it's that sort of layered miss and
honestly totally in some ways it reminds
me of Doctor Who because it is
inherently silly but is still able to
get some resonance out of it now I don't
think it's as good as Doctor Who is at
its best and I
I do think it is a little bit sillier
intentionally than Doctor Who and
doesn't quite go over the same level of
seriousness so if the the extremes of it
aren't quite on dr. whose level but it
does sort of play with that same sort of
wavering between you know sincerity and
and giving you connections and an
emotional link with the characters and
just enjoying the ridiculousness of what
it is you know it's not a bad way to go
something like robots of Sherwood
totally in many ways that feels like
legends of tomorrow feels and so for my
viewers that might actually be the best
yardstick now if you can divorce
yourself from like think about your
thought on that episode of Doctor Who
because I know most of my subscribers
are dr. who watches I know a fair amount
of fans don't really like it but ask
yourself do you not like it because you
believe it is objectively bad or do you
not like it because it's not what you
want Doctor Who to be because if you if
you can look at it and go well okay this
was fun but it's wrong for Doctor Who
you might like legends of tomorrow
because it's built from the ground up to
be that so it's it's just I have a blast
and this is one of the shows that I keep
up with with my partner Liz and we both
have so much fun with this and yeah I
just I I can keep gushing but I'm afraid
I'm gonna start getting into specific
plot points and events and spoilers and
I don't really want to do that legends
of tomorrow new season starts up soon I
cannot wait no I'm not gonna do episode
by episode reviews of it but oh I love
this show I love it so much it is so
ridiculous it is so much fun and that is
why I think legends of tomorrow is
awesome what are your thoughts on this
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
a bunch of buttons and links including
one to my patreon if you feel like
supporting me in that way if you don't
don't sweat it because remember folks
you're the council and I just run the
meetings until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]